um there's a lot of problems that come  with adoption like there's a lot of  issue like if you don't get the kid  before the age of three like it's fully  developed and any issues that it had  before the age of three a lot of times  you can't stop  um and I'm not I'm not like against  adoption but I just think sometimes it  it can a lot of people aren't aware of  how hard it is when they go into it and  this is someone like I have three  adopted siblings  no no I I totally understand that and  um I have friends  um who adopted children as well but also  it depends on  the type of person you are what parent  you will be  um  the type of child there's so many  different variations it's just kind of  like if a guy could avoid that headache  of like like you'd have to find find the  kid hope hopefully it's like coming out  of not too bad situation  um and like pain it's really expensive  too in the US I don't know how it is  here but you have to pay ten plus  thousand dollars per kid it's